oftentimes things that look risky are
not as risky as you think and things
that look safe I really not as safe as
they first seem the type of research I
do really is focused on how we could use
information to help you make better
decisions in terms of the type of risks
you want to take in terms of how much
return you would get for those risks
think about the last time you felt
nervous about something think about what
made you feel like you're vulnerable the
type of triggers that cause someone to
feel they are experiencing a lot of risk
might actually have a lot to do with
your environment and the type of things
you're paying attention to as an example
when markets are going up and they've
gone up for a little while and we what
we find is a lot of money tend to flow
into markets people feel like I should
have gotten into the market last week
people around me are all making money
and so there the sense of risk is I'm
missing the boat and so what we observe
is consistently when investor sentiment
is high money flows into the market but
what happens subsequently is that
actually when money flow into the market
the markets underperform so in fact you
think you're missing the boat and what
you're doing is stepping into a riskier
situation by investing at that time we
see the same thing happened as a bottom
of markets things start to go down
things look like they're going south
their own sudden money is flowing what
coming out of the market investor
sentiment is low you think the safe
thing to do is to get out of the market
well it turns out actually the safe
thing to do is to stay stay the course
why is to try to understand the value of
this company even if there was there
were no markets so what is the
fundamental value of a stock think of it
as how much sustainable cash flows it
could generate over the long run so try
to understand the value the other is try
to understand why today price might not
equal that value so what are the non
fundamental reasons price pressure could
move today's prize away from value it
could be because a lot of people want to
sell for a certain reason and if that's
the case wouldn't will they change their
minds most investors would like to be
stock pickers they would like to be able
to find the company the next Google
they'd like to find a Microsoft early on
but many of them don't pay attention to
defense so I think of stock picking is
like playing offense it's exciting it's
spectacular when it works but actually
defense is a huge part of being a good
investor and by defense I mean don't
take the risks that you don't intend to
take be very deliberate about how you
spend your risk budget so a good good
example is when you buy a stock like
Google you're not just buying Google you
are also making a decision for example
you take it out of your bank account to
buy Google the most important decisions
you've made is moving from cash to
stocks it's not the secondary decision
is that you've actually bought Google so
think in terms of what you are really
doing what you're doing is taking a low
volatility stock portfolio a low
volatility asset and you're converting
into a high volatility asset if you
really only like Google maybe you should
buy Google but short out the tech index
or the Nasdaq so that what you've done
is neutralized the bet you don't want a
lot of professional investors do better
because
they actually play good defense they
only make the bets that they have the
most insights on and they don't take the
risks that they actually have no
advantage taking I tell my students did
life is all about how you spend your
risk budget there's a sense in which we
will all be taking risk the question is
are these risks the ones worth taking
and is the payoff worth the risk that
you've just undertook